ladies and gentlemen The Fool Foundation
School of Engineering and Applied
Science class of 2009
ladies and gentlemen the alumni parade
of classes
ladies and gentlemen the faculty and
stage party
president Bollinger on behalf of the
Dean and the faculty of the food
foundations School of Engineering and
Applied Science and the class of 2009 I
I respectfully ask your permission to
begin these class day exercises with
that permission I shall begin president
Bollinger Dean Navratil Provost Brinkley
honor participants distinguished faculty
alumni and guests I'm proud to recognize
the members of the class of 2009 and to
make their shared and individual
accomplishments in these class days
exercises it is now my honor to present
to you the salutatorian for the food
Foundation School of Engineering and
Applied Science class of 2009 Stanley
Snelson
Thank You Dean Shellenberger something
many people experience is the difficulty
in bringing one's actions and plans in
line with ones concept of how society
should be influenced a primary goal of a
School of Engineering and Applied
Science must be to help its students
bridge this gap and our school has done
much to help us reconcile our ideals
with our life decisions many of us wrote
in our college application essays that
we wanted to change the world or work
for the benefit of society some had very
concrete ideas about what they wanted to
change and others simply said they
wanted to use their careers to help
people and whether these feelings were
genuine or whether we thought this was
what admissions committees wanted to
hear we would soon be brought face to
face with the reality of shaping society
through technology we were told early
and often that our school would not let
us forget why we came here that it would
stay committed to educating us about the
role of engineering in society and that
it expected us to do the same
while our coursework effectively raised
these issues contact with our classmates
drove the point home there is a common
purpose among the students here we have
been training to develop the technology
of the future to design the
infrastructure to meet the changes of
tomorrow but together we are determined
to do so in a certain way whatever we
design whatever we build and whatever we
do we will take account of the larger
consequences of our actions that is the
impact of our actions on society on the
economy or on the environment as the
case may warrant this sounds simple but
many of us know how easy it is to sit
comfortably in one's mastery of a skill
and ignore the tough questions about the
impact of one's actions at Columbia
these questions are never in the
background for long due to the combined
efforts of faculty and students we have
also been shaped by the diversity of
ideas within the student body we have
met people who like ourselves are
ambitious about helping Society but
have different ideas about what changes
society needs and how best to bring them
about our coursework has encouraged us
to ask whether and how our ideals can be
put into practice but contact with our
peers has forced us to question those
ideals themselves to think about other
people's visions for society and compare
them with our own this exchange has
resulted not in universal agreement but
in each person reevaluating his or her
reasons for studying engineering and
applied science we came with diverse
viewpoints and we are leaving with
viewpoints that are no less diverse but
better thought-out and more nuanced we
have seen that the world is changing
with or without action on our part and
that often the role of the engineer is
to help society adapt to a changing
world rather than to impose his or her
vision of the future onto reality
however thoughtful that vision may be in
the end this comes down to realizing
that we cannot control everything and
that sometimes we have to change with
the world even if we would like to just
change the world we have also seen that
science and technology cannot solve all
our problems low tech solutions whether
already in use long forgotten or yet to
be developed are often quite effective
and almost always more sustainable than
high tech solutions to the same problem
as important as new technologies will be
for our future remember that for most of
history communities have developed
sustainably while utilizing a far lower
level of technology
I admit these communities were less
populous than ours but think about what
I said finally while we have always
sought to understand the environmental
and social consequences of our actions
we have been shown that our activities
frequently have other less obvious
consequences when we focus on the larger
societal impact of what comes out of our
activities sometimes we neglect the
smaller scale effects related to what
goes into our projects where should we
obtain our materials how should our
products be tested and from where should
we procure funding we have not been
given a particular set of answers to
these ethical questions but we have been
convinced of the importance of asking
them
this is just my version of the role of
science and engineering in society and
now each of us must formulate his or her
own version and begin acting on that
formulation as we go on to influential
positions in industry government and
academia we will finally start working
toward the achievement of our goals and
we have been thoroughly prepared for
this opportunity by the last four years
many of us were already determined to
act on the issues that mattered to us
before we came but our experiences here
have forced us to think about these
issues further and helped us discover
how to act on them and for that we are
grateful
Thank You Stanley for the last two years
we have all had the distinct honor and
privilege to being under the leadership
of Dean Gerald Navratil his dedication
to the school and to each student is
something for which we are and will
remain grateful particularly now as he
concludes his role as Dean it's my
pleasure to welcome your Dean to the
podium the Dean of the food Foundation
School of Engineering and Applied
Science Gerald Navratil well Thank You
Dean shoenberger and I extend my welcome
to all the parents and Friends of our
graduating students to the celebration
of this very important moment in their
lives and to our graduates I offer my
heartiest congratulations to the class
of 2009 it's also very important to
recognize that you graduates are
surrounded on both sides by the parents
and family members who have nurtured you
and supported you through your studies
and are at this moment bursting with
pride and your achievements please give
all of them a round of applause in
gesture of appreciation
now our program this morning has several
speakers addressing you in honor of this
occasion and it's my privilege to
introduce to you as the first of these
the distinguished First Amendment
scholar and the 19th president of
Columbia University Li si Bollinger
thank you very much Jerry and I would
like to on behalf of the University
thank you for the service over the past
two years it is never easy to take a
position like Dean for a period of time
and to really advance the school and you
have done that we really appreciate it I
also want to recognize the families the
parents the Friends of the graduates
this is an incredibly important moment
for you we know that and we appreciate
it
so the graduates I will have an
opportunity to speak to you on Wednesday
and so my comments today are very very
short I just really want to say to you
two things one that we recognize your
public service while you've been here as
students and this has been very
important for your own lives but it's
also been important for the communities
that you have served and we very much at
Columbia value that and and appreciate
it
the second is simply a comment that is
ordinarily made but I want to give it a
personal note one of the things I've
realized in life is how little I know
about technology and having come from
the law side of the scholarly world it
has been more and more apparent to me
how deficient we are outside of your
field of engineering in understanding
what it is that you know and we often
say to you that it's extremely important
that you as engineers and people who
work in science how important it is for
you to recognize that there are values
associated with tech
nology and science and how important it
is for you to grasp the full complexity
of the subjects that you take on we've
also said to you on many occasions that
every problem every problem we face
whether its climate change or disease or
poverty or communications whatever it is
ultimately is a problem of Engineering
and Technology and science but what we
don't often say to you is that we have
more to learn from outside of your field
then you have to learn about our side of
the field and so for you I want to
acknowledge that you graduate from one
of the greatest institutions of the
world you better than almost anyone I
can think of have that capacity to
bridge both technology and values but
you also have to recognize that you must
teach us on the other side what you know
and we need to know so save some of your
happiness for Wednesday and I'll see you
then thank you
Thank You president Bollinger I would
now like to introduce the senior fund
committee co-chairs Stephanie Denning
and remya Prada watb Ankara to present
the class gift
before we begin we would like to ask the
members of the 2009 senior fund
committee to please stand
thanks for your guys's hard to work Dean
never it's young on behalf of the fou
foundation School of Engineering and
Applied Science class of 2009 we are
proud to present you today with our
senior class gift so here's a little
story as to why this gift is so
significant let's just reminisce back
when we were all first accepted to the
food foundation
most of us were probably good choice
Inge and we were hearing congratulatory
remarks left and right like wow your
life his sets and four years later we're
sitting here thinking wait is our life
really set but there is a bust
over the course of four years here at
Columbia has really taken us on a
journey to prepare us for this real
world our journey here has allowed us to
explore the talents and the potential
within ourselves and just how we can use
that in our chosen career paths along
the way we've also adopted just these
values that come from the experiences
we've had here at Columbia and those in
New York City Columbia has instilled us
with the unique qualities of passion
spirit the can-do attitude needed to
overcome any setback and carry us
forward to a better world we have faced
many many obstacles in our time here at
Columbia and this is what we do as
engineers is overcome these obstacles so
Columbia has imbued us with these
essential ingredients in order to forge
a better tomorrow to the class of 2009
and the never ending spirit and help of
the committee we thank you for playing
your part this class has made an
indelible mark in the history of the
School of Engineering and Applied
Science
you guys have paved the way in a time of
uncertainty which is why we encourage
each and every one of you to remain
active as alumni of this amazing
University Dean Navratil on behalf of
the 2009 senior fund committee
we want to present you with this scroll
on it you will find the name of every
senior who has participated in our class
gift we thank you your staff and the
Division of Student Affairs for all
their dedication and support there was a
lot going against us this year but
thanks to the commitment and dedication
of the committee and the class as a
whole we reached our goal of rage
raising four thousand five hundred
dollars their pot thereby securing a
generous matching gift of $10,000 from a
C's alumna as a result we are able to
present you with the gift of fourteen
thousand eight hundred and two dollars
and this this is the largest senior
class gift in the history of the School
of Engineering and Applied Science this
gift will aid in the improvement of life
for future students at C's we invite you
to please stand and give the class of
2009 a wrap a round of applause for
achieving this milestone despite any
setback all the while staying true to
these ideals you guys Rock
well on behalf of the food foundation
School of Engineering and Applied
Science I thank you class of 2009 for
this class gift and a special thanks to
the co-chairs of the senior class gift
committee Stephanie and Ramaiah and
their committee members who worked so
hard this past year on the senior fund
thank you very much
now just as your class set a new
benchmark this year for quality when you
arrived to columbia you've set a new
benchmark for the class gift raising
more money than any previous class this
is a very important first step in giving
back to the School of Engineering to
benefit future students who will follow
in your footsteps now in just two days
time you will officially be alumni of
the School of Engineering and Applied
Science and to help us maintain a
connection with all of you and you with
your classmates in the years ahead we
have organizations of our alumni who
will reach out to you the presidents of
the Columbia engineering Alumni
Association
Chester Lee and the newly launched
Columbia engineering young Alumni
Association Jack u n are both with us
today and I hope you will all take
advantage of the programs and events
offered by these groups of involved
alumni now on Wednesday you'll join the
number of very famous people as alumni
of the school some are world renowned
while others have made significant
contributions within their own sphere of
influence for most you may not know
their names but you do know their
accomplishments from William Barkley
Parsons class of 1882
who many's whose many accomplishments
include the building of the first New
York City subway line the Broadway line
to NASA astronaut Mike Massimino class
of 1984 who is as I'm speaking to you in
orbit above us using his engineering
talents to repair the Hubble Space
Telescope and if you follow the news he
was out of the Space Shuttle and working
on the Hubble for over eight hours
yesterday and working on the team
handling communication in Houston for
the mission is our second active NASA
astronaut Greg Johnson
who
saved his master's degree from the
School of Engineering in 1985 and who
piloted the space shuttle Endeavour last
year our alumni range from these
astronauts to Nobel laureates like
Robert Merton class of 1966 who
revolutionized the analysis of financial
markets Steve Perlman who developed web
TV and peach sauce Berg
class of 1972 whose beer Pete's wicked
ale has delighted many columbia students
and from personal experience I can say
faculty and Dean's now we point out
often our belief that engineering is the
liberal art of the 21st century it
summarizes our philosophy that many
issues of the modern world demand an
understanding of technology from human
cloning to identity theft from digital
compression to facial recognition
systems we have given you a familiarity
with these technologies which when
coupled with the traditional liberal
arts of the core curriculum position you
to be among the most knowledgeable of
citizens for each new generation of
students the school has adapted to
provide the best possible preparation
for success your unique Columbia
engineering education has given you much
you have experienced engaged
community-based learning through the
botwin ik multimedia laboratory and
early or gateway as its affectionately
known and early introduction to
professional level courses non-technical
minors hundreds of opportunities for
undergraduate research and
interdisciplinary environment in which
the study and most recently
opportunities that foster
entrepreneurship this is true for our
largest majors industrial engineering
and operations research I don't hear you
biomechanical engineering our core
engineering programs electrical
engineering mechanical engineering
alright Chemical Engineering civil
engineering and applied science programs
in computer science and computer
engineering Applied Physics applied math
material science and our oldest programs
in mining now repurposed is Earth and
environmental engineering
so with these class today and
commencement ceremonies we mark the end
of the academic year and the completion
of your years as undergraduates or
graduate students at the School of
Engineering and as you formally take
leave of us on Wednesday please remember
that you'll always be a part of the
Columbia family and I'm now inviting you
as our most recent alumni to join with
other alumni and attend Dean's day and
reunion weekend June 5th and 6th we have
many exciting social and educational
events and I suspect you'll need very
little encouragement to meet your
friends from Columbia College and
Barnard at the fillmore in New York at
Irving Plaza for casino night and
dancing on Friday June 5th
check this out any other events on the
website so while you were about to
become our newest alumni today
you're still officially students and
it's on your behalf as students that the
school honors outstanding faculty
members by means of three separate
awards the school bestows the kiemce
award for faculty involvement the Genet
and our Menominee seein's Diversity
Service Award and the Rodriguez junior
faculty development award the school is
critically aware of the importance of
the quality of student life and the need
to foster connections between students
and faculty to help each student achieve
his or her potential there are two
awards given by the school to faculty
members who exhibit exceptional concern
for students
not just in the academic arena the first
award is the Kim award for faculty
involvement established in 2000 by
Edward and Carol Kim parents of Brian
Kim class of 2001 the Kim's created this
award to honor a faculty member who is
not only an excellent teacher but also
shows a special personal commitment to
students and in recognition of his
constant caring for undergraduates I'm
pleased to present the 2009 Kim award
for faculty involvement to one of our
most distinguished senior faculty
managers David Ickes the fou foundation
professor of applied mathematics in the
department of applied physics and
applied mathematics
the second award honors faculty members
his actions encourage women and men from
diverse backgrounds to become part of
the academic community of engineering
education believing in the importance of
encouraging young people from a range of
backgrounds the school last year
instituted this award to recognize those
faculty members whose efforts assist in
this goal and University trustee and
Board of Visitors chair emeritus armineh
venetians and last year's class day
speaker class of 1983 personally
committed to this effort and has created
an endowment to fund it in perpetuity
the award known as the Jeanette and
Armen a Venetians diversity award is
given this year to Laurence Yao
professor and chair of the department of
mechanical engineering
the third faculty award the Rodriguez
family junior faculty development award
was established by two alumni of the
school Anna Rodriguez class of 86 and a
dance degree in 88 and her brother
Marcos rodriguez class of 1983 they
established this award last year to
support the advancement of
underrepresented junior faculty in our
school and I'm pleased to announce that
the winner of this year's Rodriguez
family junior faculty development award
is Jose Blanchette associate professor
in the Department of Industrial
Engineering and operations research
now in addition to awards instituted by
the school the Columbia engineering
Alumni Association presents an award for
faculty commitment to teaching
undergraduates at this time it's my
pleasure to introduce the president of
the Columbia engineering Alumni
Association Chester Lee Chester is a
1970 graduate of the School of
Engineering and a 1974 graduate of the
Columbia Business School he is a senior
business analyst with AIG domestic
brokerage group in addition to his
leadership of the Columbia engineering
Alumni Association he is a board member
of the Society of Columbia graduates a
founding member of the Asian Columbia
Alumni Association and served on the
university-wide steering committee that
formulated the first constitution of the
Columbia Alumni Association for his
service to Columbia he was awarded the
University Alumni medal at commencement
last year this is my pleasure
Chester Lee
Thank You teen Navratil hey Columbia
engineers let's hear from the class of
2009 give yourself a warm round of
applause for years of coming on and you
about to embark a new journey beyond
Columbia's familiar walls I wish you
much success whether you're starting
your professional career or going on to
graduate school should be very proud of
your Columbia degree the stand you in
good stead as you connect with very
successful alumni around the world from
all walks of life only three short years
ago in 2006 I sat where your parents are
today and watch my son Douglas walk
across this very stage of the candidate
for The Bachelor of Science degree by
the way he majored in engineering
management science in the IO II or our
department by many of you little des I
realized that I would be parties
ceremonies in 2009 as president of
Columbia engineering Alumni Association
I am pleased to welcome the class of
2009 as our newest alumni and later in a
ceremony I will convey my good wishes to
you personally as you come across the
stage to receive your class pin I also
like to take a moment to thank Dean
Navratil for his outstanding service and
leadership as our interim dean these
last two years his energy and dedication
have propelled the school's positive
momentum and as a result C's has never
been in better shape both academically
and financially Thank You Dean Navratil
for your efforts on behalf of students
faculty and alumni
my role here today is to acknowledge the
dual responsibilities of C's faculty for
excellence of both teaching and research
at Columbia the faculty eagerly accepts
this dual role the research
accomplishments are attested to by their
peers and by their numerous publication
and awards today we attest to the
excellence in teaching based upon
feedback from their students in 1997 the
Columbia Engineering School Alumni
Association Institute's the
distinguished faculty Teaching Award to
emphasize the superior quality of
undergraduate teaching that takes place
in the school to permanently recognize
the destinies the Alumni Association
commissioned the plaque to display their
names
this plaque now hands hangs an occult
and lounge the center's Student Activity
in the school each of our recipients
receives a miniature version of that
plaque along with the honorarium the
distinguished faculty teaching award is
given on behalf of the students and
alumni of Columbia University's food
Foundation School of Engineering and
Applied Science for excellence in
teaching including dedication to
undergraduate students based upon
student evaluations and the
recommendations of the selection
committee that Columbia engineering
student Engineering Alumni Association
today honors professor Julia Hirschberg
and professor David yaw as recipients of
this year's distinguished faculty
Teaching Award
dr. Hirschberg is a distinguished
professor in the department of computer
science she has taught introduction to
knack natural language processing and a
course in spoken language processing
this fall she would be teaching a course
entitled computational approaches to
emotional speech dr. Hirschberg received
their PhD in computer science from the
University of Pennsylvania after
previously doing a PhD in
sixteenth-century Mexican social history
at the University of Michigan and
teaching history at Smith she has worked
at Bell Laboratories at 8 and 18 T
laboratories as a member of the
technical staff and as a department head
starring the human-computer interface
research research department there she
has served as editor-in-chief of
computational linguistics and was
editor-in-chief of the publication's
speech communication dr. Hirsh Berg has
been a fellow of the American
Association for artificial intelligence
since 1994 and the fellow of the
International speech communication
Association since 2008
not the yowsa professor in the
Department of Industrial Engineering
operations research is teaching a
research interests or sarcastic models
queues and queuing networks focusing on
the analysis design and control
stochastic systems such as manufacturing
systems supply chains and supply chain
logistics dr. Yahoo's author a co-author
over 160 refereed publications three
books and five edited volumes not the
yeah received his PhD from the
University of Toronto and was associate
professor Harvard before coming to
Columbia as a full professor at Columbia
engineering has been the principal
architect of the highly successful and
nationally ranked master's degree
program and financial engineering his
numerous honors and awards include being
named a Guggenheim Fellow the franz
Edelman award from the Institute for
operations research search and
Management Sciences
yeah outstanding a paper prize from the
Society for industrial and applied
mathematics the outstanding technical
team award and the industrial Chipman
award from IBM Research the qualities
that make these professors deserving of
this award are common to both a caring
attitude approachability responsiveness
to student concerns and the ability to
Lucent ly teach essential skills and
complex subject matter today the
Columbia engineering Alumni Association
takes pride in joining with you the
class of 2009 and honoring these two
distinguished teachers so with great
appreciation for the enthusiastic
dedication to excellence in teaching our
undergraduates I am proud to present
these awards to Professor Julia
Hirschberg and professor David Yahoo
Thank You mr. Lee in each class there
are men and women who distinguish
themselves and their school by their
academic accomplishments and service to
others in your program you will find a
list of the departmental awards and the
names of the recipients of those awards
also over the past few weeks we have
recognized students who have given their
time and talents to enhance our Columbia
community at this time while all those
students who receive departmental Awards
who were selected as senior marshals or
who were honored at the king's crown
leadership award dinner please stand and
be recognized
other award recipients thank you so much
for your service we now would like to
present the final awards given by the
food foundation School of Engineering
Applied Science the distinguished class
prize Awards the School of Engineering
and Applied Science scholar athlete
award is presented by the office of the
Dean to the graduating student who has
distinguished himself or herself as a
varsity athlete and scholar this year
the award is given to Jonathan Chan
the George Vinson window memorial medal
was established in 1924 by friends in
the alumni and faculty the late
professor George Winston Bendel to honor
and perpetuate his memory
each department nominates one student
and the awardees are selected by the
vote of the senior class this year the
award is given to Michael sue
the School of Engineering and Applied
Science Student Activities Award its
presented to the undergraduate degree
candidate who by virtue of his or her
willingness energy and leadership has
significantly contributed to the
co-curricular life of the school this
year I'm very happy to present the award
to Lauren Mitch's
the campus life Leadership Awards are
conferred from time to time to the
student or students who participated and
involvement in undergraduate campus life
at Columbia have enhanced the very
spirit of student life on campus and
I've created a more purposeful caring
and celebratory community at large the
measure of the undergraduate experience
can be found not only in academics but
in the service and acceptance that one
extends to others the recipients of the
award have been successful in their
endeavors to create a more understanding
and accepting environment that prove
that preserves the ideals and heritage
of the school the 2009 recipients are
maritza Harper Kimberly manis and Joanne
Rispoli
the Constantino Colombo outstanding
leadership service award is presented to
an engineering student who has
demonstrated outstanding leadership and
service while working with a broad base
of undergraduate constituents and
administrators to enhance undergraduate
student life the award is presented in
honor of Chris Colombo who served for 16
years as the Dean of Student Affairs
this year's award for the first time is
awarded to Brian Smith
the Charles candle award was created by
the Alumni Association and memories of
Charles candle class of 1911 civil
engineering his tireless efforts were
devoted to helping undergraduate
Engineers prepare for the realities of
professional life after graduation the
criteria for selection are promoting the
best interest of Columbia in general
partaking in co-curricular activities
connected with the School of Engineering
and Applied Science actively
contributing to Student Alumni affairs
and given evidence by specific conduct
or by his or her appreciation other
traditions established by past and
present Engineering alum and recognition
of the responsibility to uphold this
those traditions this year's recipient
is Peter Valeris
the Thomas pop Harrington metal it's
awarded to that student in the
graduating class who best exemplifies
the qualities of character that
Professor Harrington exhibit exhibited
during his 40 years of teaching at the
School of Engineering from 1894 to 1935
the Harrington medal is made possible by
the generous and deeply appreciated gift
from dr. Myron a Kohler
BS 1934 PhD 1937 this medal is given to
Peter Belarus
can we have another round of applause
for all our prize winners so last award
the Illig medal is the highest honor
awarded to an engineering graduate the
final prize is given to our
valedictorian the student with the
highest average the Illig medal was
established in 1898 by the quest from
William C L ik e m 1882
and is awarded by the faculty to a
member of the graduating class for
commendable proficiency in his or her
studies we would now like to
congratulate this year's recipient of
the Illig metal and Ballack Victorian of
the class of 2009 John Stankiewicz
Thank You Dean Shawn burger good morning
everyone good morning class of 2009
before anything else I'd like to thank
our faculty families and friends for all
the wonderful support you've given us
over the past four years when I first
realized that I would be giving a speech
today I admittedly felt a certain degree
of unease so in search of some help
I asked my adviser professor Suleiman
Kashani what he thought I should do his
response make it rhyme I'm not quite
sure if he was joking I asked my
girlfriend the same question and her
response was write a speech that an
engineer would write so what would an
engineer say as engineers we've been
taught the self problem systematically
and the first step is solving any
problem is to break it in two steps
step one identify the problem
in my case hot rod a graduation speech
step to determine the goals a coherent
speech maybe some useful advice not
looking foolish in front of the entire
class okay
systematically breaking down problems
and de steps like this is something
we've all learned to embrace as
engineers as for students in industrial
and engineering and operations research
our most important systematic tool is
optimization
essentially we take problems subject to
specific constraints and try to achieve
the best or optimal outcome using
mathematics and computer programming now
typically this process is applied to
things like managing inventory or
constructing an optional optimal
investment portfolio but as students we
solve our own optimization problems all
the time we all have goals that we
strive for and often we meet certain
constraints sometimes beyond our control
that may force us to make some
sacrifices in light of the world's
current economic state many of us
changed her plans and pursued
opportunities we hadn't considered
before but even the economic downturn
itself is an opportunity for us to apply
what we've learned as engineers we're
graduating with many of the tools
necessary to solve real world problems
most of the major challenges facing the
world today whether they relate to the
economy energy healthcare population
growth I'll invite an application of the
creativity and skills that we have
acquired as engineers it then becomes
our individual responsibility to figure
out how our personal objectives dictate
the impact we will have upon these
larger issues but does the comparison
stop here we obviously should not
literally approach our lives like an
optimization problem we don't have
singular life goals and our constraints
are not well-defined
so how do we know we are making the
right choices well maybe it's not the
elusive optimum that dictates our
choices maybe our choices shape our
life's optimum frezz we grow older we
may make many life decisions but our end
result will always inherently be the
best by the simple fact that our choices
led us there so instead of trying to
optimize our lives a little our lives to
create what's best this I believe is
truly the right solution
now as I close I like to act as any good
engineer would fork all my goals and
check over my work a coherent speech
some useful information hopefully
but now at the risk of looking foolish
that professor kotani's request I
finished with this address and to
Burgess I am contrite fry ambach
tetrameter is too hard to write a few
words that rhyme for the class of 2009
Columbia sees four years now
commencement Day nears past our first
year moving day past those dinners at
John Jay through sophomore year seeking
more through CC econ the rest of the
core junior years some funds some stress
in engineering degree in progress
then comes senior year a blast can't
believe it came so fast
decisions decisions have to be made and
for our futures plans are laid now I
don't want this thing to drag too long
conclude it with a quote and end it
strong and so as Theodore gazelle would
say that's dr. Seuss by the way today
you are you that is truer than true
there was no one alive who is you er
than you all I can do to finish this
rhyme congratulations class of 2009
well thank you John and congratulations
it's now my great pleasure to introduce
your class day speaker james alba
executive vice president of the boeing
company and a leader in the aerospace
industry jim received a similar
engineering master's degree from the
school of engineering in 1974 as a
matter of fact this marks the 35th
anniversary of his graduation and on
that day he probably did not imagine
that it he'd be back here addressing
future graduates as the class day
speaker now one day decades from now one
of you sitting in today's audience as a
candidate for graduation may indeed be
the keynote speaker at that future class
day given your talents and the
preparation you've received here the
probability is in fact quite high so
you'll want to pay very close attention
now when Jim left Columbia he became a
project engineer and moving up the
corporate ladder eventually was
appointed president of Rocketdyne
propulsion and power which Boeing
acquired in 1996 he served briefly as
president of Boeing space transportation
and in 1998 was named president and
chief executive of Boeing space and
communications in 2002 when that unit
merged the company's military and
missiles systems unit Jim was appointed
president and chief executive officer of
the newly formed integrated defense
systems it's very appropriate as we have
two of our astronaut alumni now engaged
in a space mission to have Jim with us
today as you know Boeing space
exploration has been a vital part of
this nation's journey into space from
Gemini Apollo and Skylab to the space
shuttle and the International Space
Station and to the newest constellation
project that will help astronauts return
to the moon by 2020
Jim is a fellow of the American
Institute of Aeronautics and
Astronautics an elected member of the
International Academy of astronautics
and a fellow of the Royal Aeronautical
Society he's also a trustee of
Willamette University in Salem Oregon
from which he received his bachelor's
degree in mathematics and physics he was
the guest speaker for our McGill lecture
during Reunion Weekend in 2002 and it's
my pleasure to welcome Jim again to the
Columbia campus please welcome Jim
Albaugh
well thank you Dean it's a pleasure to
be here you look like you're having a
lot of fun today probably a lot more fun
than you had the last four years maybe
at times that really is a pleasure for
me to be here today and welcome you into
a great profession you know that of
engineering and I look out and I think
about all the things that you'll be
working on your careers and I really do
wish that I was starting over again and
as Dean Navratil you know mentioned
never in my wildest dreams that I think
that I'd be your family or your speaker
here today I'm certain my professors
feel the same way about it
before I begin let me congratulate all
the members of this class you ever every
reason to be proud you have worked very
hard so one more time around of applause
for the class of 2009
now let me also congratulate the parents
spouses and other loved ones that are
here today for their support and
encouragement and yes investment
financially and otherwise and you're
getting to this day you know I hope the
the newfound discretionary income that
you'll get as a result of today
you'll take great great joy in you know
it is nice to be back in the
neighborhood and back on campus and
driving at Broadway today I was happy to
see that Tom's restaurant was still
there although I was a little
disappointed at the West End Tavern was
gone I'm not sure when that place went
out of business but it does bring back
you know great memories of professors
and also classmates the professor's
pushed me and the students did as well
and here at Columbia I competed against
the best in the world just as you did
and it served me well as I compete
against the best in the world
in the industry that I'm in today when I
started to prepare for this class day I
tried to think back to the speaker who
talked to my class 35 years ago and
quite frankly I can't remember who it
was or anything that he talked about so
I certainly don't expect you to remember
me or or much of what I say I'll try to
be brief I'll try to give you a couple
of points to think about and I'll let
you get on with the celebration that I
understand is going to go on for about
three days around here
now who would have thought when I
graduated from Columbia in 1974 just
before a President of the United States
left the White House that we would be
seeing the inauguration of a Columbia
Graduate Barack Obama and I think it's
significant that he went here the first
black American president there's
somebody we all take a lot of pride in
before I talk about the futures that you
face let me just say a few things about
myself a few things that weren't said in
that kind introduction but as an
undergraduate I went to a small liberal
arts school and I was going to major in
history but I wind up majoring in math
and physics but I took a lot of
in that liberal arts education that I
had I learned how to write and
communicate I learned how to think and I
learned a lot about myself and I brought
all of those things here to Columbia in
preparation to be an engineer
I grew up on a small town in eastern
Washington State on the banks of the
Columbia River and what I wanted to do
when I graduated was to build dams
unfortunately I hadn't done my my
homework and all the good dam sites were
already taken so I became a rocket
scientist instead and and when you think
about it there's a lot in common between
rocket engines and dams dams are all
about stress and fluid flow and rocket
engines are both stress fluid flow and
gas flow but I was fortunate enough to
join the aerospace company the aerospace
industry in the final quarter of a very
remarkable century and I really believe
that aerospace did more to change the
20th century than any other industry in
world war ii you know dozens of new
airplanes were designed and produced the
world was brought closer together with
the advent of commercial jet travel and
then of course aerospace also changed
the way we communicate with
communication satellites and I know
there are a few people here today
you know old enough as I am or as old as
I am if you remember when it was a big
deal on television to hear the words you
know live via satellite and of course
aerospace forever changed the way that
we looked at the world around us when
man first walked on the moon how could a
young engineer not want to be part of
all of that and the firm the first day
it was great to be an engineer I got to
work on hard things I got to work with
tremendous people and I got a chance to
support fantastic customers but I also
learned a very fundamental truth about
engineering and that is there are no
shortcuts in what we do we deal in
numbers analysis and assumptions and at
the end of it all it has to be right the
people's lives depend on it
and if not lives business case
do one of the best things about my job
is I get to fly and some of the products
we build you know airplanes like the
f-15 the f-18 c-17 helicopters and I fly
with confidence because I know of all
the hard work and all the attention to
detail that went in to making those
airplanes safe and reliable yes the no
shortcuts to engineering and I'm sure
that that brings a little solace to the
impatient but also know there's great
joy in creating things that never
existed before you know I'm of a
generation that was inspired by Sputnik
and a space race there's a generation
that built mighty spaceships to go to
the moon and explore the universe yours
is a generation that must use your
engineering skills to rebuild and yes to
save the spaceship we're all on together
our planet Earth you'll find solutions
to global warming energy dependence
health care you know get a chance to
rebuild the infrastructure of this
country and of the world now quite
frankly I'm worried about this country
and its ability to address these
important issues
there aren't enough people going into
engineering and our engineering
workforce is aging at Boeing 25% of our
engineers could retire today if they so
chose 60% of our employees are above the
age of 45 the United States has become a
net importer of technology and research
and development spending is down it's
imperative that the United States guard
against what I call this intellectual
disarmament of our country we must
attract the best and brightest young
minds like yours to engineering we must
dare young people to dream again with
great goals that challenge us to explore
new frontiers so I can't think of a more
important task than the one you are
facing saving our planet I salute you
for the choice you've made and I welcome
you into this profession I was very
encouraged three weeks ago when
President Obama told the National
Academies of science the science is more
essential for our prosperity our
security our health
our environment and our quality of life
than ever before I applaud his call for
the largest commitment to scientific
research and innovation in American
history
he called for investing 3 percent of our
GDP on research and development that may
sound ambitious that our salsa essential
and I believe it's attainable by pooling
money talent and the intellectual
capacity of government industry and
academia we can meet the challenges that
the president listed you know I entered
the engineering ranks in the 70s in the
midst of an economic downturn in the
Cold War today the economic troubles are
back and the challenges we face are more
daunting than before and the problem
solvers will be each of you so how do
you get there in that vein you probably
I thought I might give you a little
career advice
so Allah I'll try not to disappoint you
may wonder how to Dirac it scientist an
engineer become a CEO first of all in
the world we live in today as dependent
as it is on technology I believe a
technical background is invaluable to be
successful you know I know I can teach
an engineer how to be a businessman or a
businesswoman I'm not sure I can teach a
business major how to be an engineer I
know my grades would have been a lot
better here at Columbia if I had to
spend a couple of hours every night up
on the guy from the b-school with her
homework
you know I never aspired or had a plan
to get into management into the role I'm
in today I just tried to do the best I
could in every job I had and I thought
every job I had would be the last one
and the best one about whatever have I
tried to work for people who I respected
and who cared about helping me grow and
helping me learn I've never got up in
the morning and not wanted to go to work
to help my team do important things in
observation I've made over the years is
that people who are focused on their
next job generally don't do very well in
the job that they have so focus on the
job that you have it's pointless to try
to predict where you'll be in 20 years
anyway if you're graduating from one of
the finest schools in the world and
you'll be working alongside students
from other great schools so listen be
inclusive you can learn from everyone
recognize that you won't always have the
right answers but if you have an answer
or an opinion or even more importantly a
question or a concern speak up
one of my biggest frustrations is going
to a meeting and knowing that there's
someone there who has an answer or a
question somebody that can help us come
to the right conclusion but for whatever
reason they're reluctant to speak up
well that's the most junior person of
the room or an executive that's why
they're being paid by their company for
their opinions and their ideas you know
that said an element of wisdom is
knowing that you don't already have the
right answers and when you get out into
life you'll quickly learn that the
answers are no longer in the back of the
book now eventually
now eventually when you do think you
have all the answers
they'll probably make you a manager but
more importantly hopefully you become a
leader both are critical but they're
very different you know manager is all
about making sure we do things tomorrow
the way we do things today a leader is
all about making sure that we inspire
people to do great things and to do
things differently in the future when
you're leading a team they're also
things you'll learn you'll learn that
people to find the company not you the
diversity of thought and inclusiveness
will always get you to the best answer
you'll know why people like the jobs
they do because they get to learn
because you get to do important work and
because they're appreciated trusted and
respected for what they do you'll
recognize that your role as a leader is
about creating a collective sense of
identity an alignment with your
organization and a shared destiny with
your employees and that developing your
people and yourself is the most
important and rewarding thing that you
can do you know what Boeing they say
that to get ahead you have to be a
friend of Jim's you have to be an foj
and it's and that's very true you do but
it's very easy to become one all you
have to do is put the company before
yourself people are working on their own
personal agenda instead of the companies
don't do very well with me as they grow
older you'll learn that the cost of
inaction is more than the cost of
occasionally being wrong and that you
never have all the information you need
to make a decision at some point it will
come down to your personal judgment and
your personal values and I can't
emphasize how important performing with
integrity is Andrew Carnegie once said
there are two types of people who don't
get very far in life one is the type who
cannot do what they're told and the
other type is the one who can do nothing
else in life and in business nothing is
black and white everything is a shade of
gray in every day that I I go to work I
bring things that I was lucky enough
to have given to me by the mentors that
have had along the way is they've gone
from New York to Washington State to
Texas to Southern California to st.
Louis Missouri and a Washington DC
they taught me lessons in leadership
they could only be developed through
hard work trial and error
failure and success not from the pages
of books
today's stores are filled with books on
the latest theories of management but
the most successful management styles
are those basic philosophies that have
guided companies for centuries I
remember early in my career listening to
Lee Atwood one of the founders of North
American Aviation a company had taken
over by the Boeing Company and Lee was
talking at a leadership meeting he said
simply put results count he stated the
obvious but it's a simple fact that
often gets forgotten
it's not about PR it's not about slick
proposals or presentations it's not
about who you know or your personality
it's about delivering on the promises
that you make to your co-workers and
your customers now years later he's
still right he went on to say no person
an organization can amount to much
unless he or it pursues a straight
course to a worthy goal from my
perspective there is no worthier goal
than what engineer seek to do improve
the quality of life here on earth since
I began my career I've seen a lot of
things change I I came to Columbia with
a slide rule I left with the calculator
and I think I've got six computers today
we started with letters we went to email
Facebook and I'm not really comfortable
this Twitter thing yet but I understand
there's some of that going on too
I've seen a huge consolidation in the
industry I've seen a threat environment
that's much more dangerous and complex
than any that we've seen since the Cold
War we've gone from the Industrial
Revolution to the information revolution
we've seen globalization change markets
in the competitive landscape we're
seeing the balance of power moved
the United States and Europe to Asia and
the Indian subcontinent I envy all of
you and what you will see and experience
in your lifetime if I can give you some
final advice it is commit to lifelong
learning technology changes so fast
speak up give your opinion that's that's
what you will be paid for recognize
these to make mistakes and life will
hand you setbacks I've written down a
billion dollars twice and I still have
my job and to put your team's or
companies ahead of yourself
choose your bosses wisely never
compromise your integrity and believe in
yourself and your dreams
now I've enjoyed my career immensely
I've been to fascinating places I've met
interesting people and have worked on
some of the most complex problems ever
undertaken I've helped people go to
space and worked on systems and
servicemen and servicewomen trust their
lives - I can't imagine the things that
you will do being here today makes me
wish I was starting all over again
now just as technology revela
revolutionized the world the last
century you and people like you will
dictate the kind of world we live in in
the 21st century and I know you'll be
able stewards and so in closing I'd like
to offer something that puts into
perspective what I think you'll be able
to do now this year marked the 50th
anniversary the first coast-to-coast
commercial flight of a Boeing 707 a Los
Angeles Times reporter was on board and
when the airplane landed here New York
he wrote the shrinking effect of the
jetliner upon geography distorted the
earth faced the planes enchanting
quality consists precisely this
capability to display shapes categories
images and events that pretty much
speaks to the incredible power of
engineering the power that you wield I
wish you all the best and I will be
accepting resumes at the back of the
room later today but thank you very much
for the honor of being here today and
good luck
Thank You mr. Alba it's now my pleasure
to introduce to you your president of
the class Kim manis good morning
president Bollinger Dean Navratil Dean
shoenberger mr. Alba mr. Lee family
friends and fellow members of the class
of 2009 we've almost made it we've
handed in our last problem sets
completed our final projects and taken
our last exams all we have to do now is
walk across the stage when I applied to
Columbia I was torn about whether to
apply to Columbia College or to sees my
older brother was then a senior in the
college and warned me against all the
hard classes and stricter course
requirements but I decided to go with
Columbia Engineering my high school
focused on the humanities and I wanted
to study math and science
I felt Columbia engineering would be a
good fit because I would get to do just
that but I'd still have a chance to take
some completely unrelated courses in
case I missed those English and history
classes I'd grown so sick of in high
school in my first two years in C's I
took two electives the rest are
requirements for the core four C's or
from my major while working my way
through these classes I often wondered
why I needed to learn any of this why is
a computer science major do I need to
read Hegel or listen to Bach how would
that help me with my engineering degree
as I entered the second half of college
to my surprise I began to notice things
I'd learned in other courses coming up
again
physics showed up in my computer vision
course probability showed up in my
biometrics course linear algebra showed
up and pretty much everything but what
was more surprising to me was when my
engineering courses and my humanities
courses began to overlap reading to cart
and CC and using his Cartesian system in
calculus learning about Adam Smith's
theories in economics and
what he what wrote in Wealth of Nations
listening to my intro to film teacher on
trying unsuccessfully to explain the
concept of depth of fields while I
recited the formula in my head and then
it started happening in real life my
linguistics class last semester had a
weekly problem set which meant each week
over 100 students needed to pick up
their graded assignments each week my
fellow computer scientists and I ordered
argue over how to maximize the
efficiency of returning our papers or
when waiting in a long line I would
begin to wonder whether the wait will be
exponentially distributed sees has also
ruined more than a few movies for me my
engineering friends and I went to see 21
and all unanimously groaned as Kevin
Spacey battled nonsensically about
derivatives and nonlinear algorithms
there have been many times throughout my
four years during those all-nighters
impossible midterms and unsolvable
programming assignments that I kick
myself for checking that C's box on my
Columbia application but whenever I have
those engineering moments out in the
real non engineering world I realized
that's why I checked the C's box Jesus
taught me a new way to see the world I
would like to take a moment to thank all
the faculty that have helped my fellow
students and I succeed during our time
here you have influenced in more ways
than you can know and years from now we
may we may not remember exactly what you
taught us but we will remember you I
would also like to thank my parents for
always supporting and believing me my
brother for constantly pushing me to
strive for more my grandparents for
thinking everything I do is amazing
whether or not it actually is and my
friends for going through all of this
with me and being there for me every
step of the way I cannot express how
much your love and support has meant to
me fellow students whether or not you'll
actually be doing anything engineering
related next year I ask that every now
and then when you have one of those
nerdy engineering moments you stop and
think back on your time and cease and
remember you are an engineer
at this time three leaders of our alumni
community
Chester Lee Daniel Shue Avella and Jack
Yun will present each member of the
class of 2009 with the excision insignia
of the school on behalf of Columbia
engineering and Alumni Association this
will officially welcome graduates to
their hard-earned status as alumni I do
ask that you please refrain from
applause until all members of the class
have returned to their seats we will now
have the reading of the names
Henry Rosenwald Rosenwald hemant poets
Morgan Tyler would come Robert Barrett
winegar Wei Zheng dong Samantha Edna
Edna
Wilner Sue Ann Michelle Rispoli Marissa
Therese Harper
Peter Henry Valerius Brian Anthony Smith
Jonathan Chen Stephanie Marie on yes
Bening Laura finches Jennifer Carrie
'pretty from young Raghavan
rowdy rowdy by Ankara Amanda
Ricky Lori Amy
ciao Gao mikail
Klaassen Hanna Leigh Samuel rashaam
subbarao prashanta see Dunstan Michael
foo ireenie Rose focus james chan j side
Samantha
John Lee Lee Wang Qiang GU Jeremy Micah
Seltzer got one wrong crystal though
Jason Adam Eckstein Andrew John Sabatino
Rafael Almeida says are Alfonso Aguilar
Matias Earhart bulky Jonathan Hutchinson
Beck Ivan Highberger baleen stone Eric
Justin felassan Oh Brian math grew more
and more on Oh Laura
Allison McKay Patti Lynne Mallory
Brianne for to juice Sookie
Nancy Fang Zhang Muhammad Nabeel aglow
James Whitlock Benner Jeffrey Andrew
valerka Emile Hassan II D s Phillip
Andrew McCook Anthony Olivo Paul
rasullah Mensa Bonsu Laurieann Gail Oh
Olivia subbu Jorge Orlando portal Laura
Katherine Viner
Andrew Henry Arnold
Ryan David Cornell Chrissy Cassell
Zambrano Sophie Ning Jing qu chanita
Rachelle Nicholas Brian John Hobgood Oh
golly
Avani Oh ego voda Andrew Scott Mason
Bret Alexander bennewitz Brittany Lynn
Broder Samantha Lee Hanson Elsa
Schneider's Daniel Aaron Bosson ishbal
Eugene Y Co Jason Jun Tong Wong Javier
Francisco Bolanos Andrew Joseph from
burger John Gordon Atlas Min Soo Justin
yech Andrew hey Randy Michelle Naugatuck
Matteo Matthew trois kill Steiner Roman
Stouffer Daniel brew Jeff
Helen Timothy Kenji O'Neill sungjoo him
he Beck sing Ross Owen Beaubourg Rachel
Rita
first Alan Sean puffier writer
Kalani on oppa Frederico Jose Garcia
citron Sarma bungalow Damian and
Chukotka bitch
Travis Benjamin Thurber Matthew Ronald
we doe hang shoo Samuel Santiago Lara
Danny Chung King you my run chen GAO
shannon nicole Hosie Lauren Elyse
Ehrlich Christian Stenberg Isaac Alya ha
new Kohanim Derek Michael Watson Taylor
John I can sear Evan Stein Rohan pet Oh
Andrew I Kim Claudio Stefan Andrew
Joseph Radosevich Alicia
Viva Ling Glen gomez Lata priest Narni
leg garage Kaushik
Vikram Ashok Tim Palmer Michael Brandon
Lynn
Oh funky Agnes la Sunday Nancy dear
Amanda Marie MacDermott Mika Berkowitz
pegas balloon boiler Samantha Marie
Porter Thomas T tau at Asylum is pizza
Valerio sona's Nikhil can't Gupta John
David Allison Tom hanshan 10 Anthony
Wong Daniel ko Benjamin I Kim Paul sang
Lee Joel you Jessica Yi Ling Lou
Jason Philip Terence Park Raoul dear
Kyle Levinson Davies Vivek Mercker G
Joshua and roof
Narciso Paul Chappelle anniver Bryant
Collins ruff Daniel Patrick cool Ramon
almost Torres Andrew Thomas Macaulay so
Christopher John Kay Lou
Laura Elizabeth and Smith and thou Lee
ho Yong Chan Richard Eisen cruel to hang
you Dean Michael Dean Schumann Everett's
Lynn Jian way he'd Karen Zhi Cheng Andre
Alexander kirochka n-- Savior duche
Jordan Jeffrey Ruprecht
Shawn Evan Cleary Charles J Chang Ian
Dow boom
Brian Hsieh Jin yoshikawa Paul William
visa Audrey Seco shihara Rebecca Jarvis
Angela and weary Patrick
Daniel Houston Andrew Wyatt
Ryan Quinn Michael Paul runny Eli
Benjamin waltz Robert Allen sekolah
Charles yokan young bow to shun you Chow
son
chuny i wing Vanessa ciao
Linda wrong Angela
Margaret fan Robert Chen Michael
Donnellan Cheng Yi Chen Benjamin Wong
Jefferson Lin Chen Yu Jiang
Andrew Victor young been wrong
Christopher Daniel Piero Stephen chain
Kenneth eating ten Sarah mcaro Jeff Jung
Han Chang Abraham Baruch Stifel re
Greenspan Nathan Tish Berg v le
caroli
Donny Reuben gigantic Mirza Sajal Andrew
min boy bucyk William chin
Pamela son de la Cruz Steven Mong Andrea
June Yi Chen Stephanie gie Ken Alyssa
Danielle Rios Pat livadas Sri Reptar
Ashok Ivanka Ivanka vote Michael Chang
Patrick Victor prayed oh man well
Mauricio Mitrano Hilary Kate Schneider
Miller Sierra in boy Christopher John
White
Shonda knee socks Anya Maya sin wotty
wot some nice treat na vi's Ricky push a
Patel will Gabriel Schuessler Shana
Elise gray boys Philip Henry paddle on
Oh Michael Christopher beaten Steven
John slivko Michelle Dominique Bruce
Aaron Jackson Lennon David Eric David
Smith John Anthony Coons Scott Kim
Peltier Patrick a Duggan Ryan Haywood
Cochran Burchard st. Clair green
Courtney Catherine celebrate Alison
Darlene Magnon Oh
Julie and Haney Leah
Elizabeth Peterson levy Israel stark
amar
Nathaniel Nussbaum Theresa Lynn stark
Peter John Fredricksen Nathan Leonard
Lyle's Tiffany Kwan Francis Lou
Sabrina Sablan Monteverde yo Mary Espen
all joy and toriel Colburn Lennon
routing Lee Eric Owens Layla who SHM on
Haley Lauren dorsal Alexi Zelan Berg
Philip Scott Kent Mary Theresa Mona Han
Pendergast Alexander Digby Williams Mark
Lombardi Chi Chi Philip liao Andrew
Michael Dixon ample out David John young
Jason de Paul Edwards taya Zim Nikki P
odor and Ray logic Nicholas cylinder
night coach Oh che before J do obg Ola
no hace teeth
Kenneth Antony Yearwood Christian colas
a new Michael William Gerson Benjamin
David Benjamin Albert Steven Michael
Thomas
Antonia area and jelly no Arjun Roy Luis
Carlos Quintero's Alan Geum
Nathan Weiss Lauren Elizabeth Zielinski
Lauren see Fong Prospero one Arturo
Herrera Phillip GMOs Andrew William
Thomas Artem Schneider
Alexander come Grabeel avi Ferrari
Sally hoon Kim Jung ah Francesca Wong
David Young Williams Steven seung-hyun
Cole vamsee boba Kelly Amanda - Andrew
Taven Kim Sevilla bar Riku Boris men
Zack max Frank Sepang ski Tristan gnomon
rohith's Warren car Patrick Michael
Alexander Kyle Jacob Shoals to come
Gottfried goof on key
Filipa Niko sock way Shawn Darcy
Richard Dunphy Joyce Marshall Edward Fox
look Candace young Ricardo Alberto
Saavedra Joshua Wayne Sutherland John
Lee Andrew nan way soo Jung Jun Paul
Park he Julie
Amaya Nicole BT
Alfred kima Asante chinito pay s allude
Appa Daniel Alberto Daniel Alberto
Pacheco christopher Allen Thomas Edward
Peter boson G Coastie Kufa Ross Matthew
Myers mark Edward Buckland seen on lead
Ashish Kundra suruci Ahuja Sanjay on
Asia
Rahul Johar Kumar James Warren Karpel
Rodrigue NIM each Pradeep Maeda
Jonathan Alexander patate Craig and Rue
Danton Buddha Rafa e man L Alam Amandine
Florence his then go da Zachary reneik
Annette Belle James lang Victor Mateus
Cristian Amparo dawa's Michael mark
Kokoschka michael mattos ed long J
Julius chewed out avi grew met Esther
joy Zuckerman Lynn Lynn son Daniel
Bridger with Anastasia hopes Ava Albina
Shapiro Tyler Martin Hendry Kelly Lynne
Russell
Emily Louise Marquardt
Peter Isaac pepper arrow Michael Jared
cosden Nishi kg Danya Michael Ethan
Hanken an on Reggie sworen Anshu das
Christopher Michael Williams
Noren dilarosa Kyle Jang
Akhil Ajay bataya Abed Rove baba ki
Robert John Vlasic Anthony Blair Paul
Allen ekeus s Rickon J Shah given Carini
Lu Luisa Zheng Albert Lee Jonathan you
Eric hoon Chung Jonathan and Robert
Zippo Lee Tianna mu Z sangwon Kim
Cellini Lee Tehran
i Liu Li Tiffany - blue Ingrid wing kwon
jae Xu Xu Lu Jo Jae Gwang Felix Felix
lung Ying you Benjamin lie
Clara Leah Sussman Raphael Yahoo Dakar
yuckier Greenbaum Salem Abra Aaron taken
Mitchell Seth Berlin David William
Norris at this time we will present the
candidates for the Master of Science and
professional degrees Sinclair yay Arthur
Mick know how to Mitsu
Aizawa Rami ha boss
Rajesh Venkataraman Brian Michael yuck
Abby shake side knock Midori ERT Joshi
Chitra Agassi truck tech jun kim shun
column Aurora
Joseph S Troy William Wow Inu old son
let's see Lee McKenzie Claire pre Murano
erica lynn tyler our sanity cool con tam
kit un zuleyka any yacht
Noah Samuel Corwin meek lon
Kyle Roswell Soraya's srivatsa gorras
quantum Narayan think and toss the war
on Anita
my poor son dream deal on Simon Seema
Maha Danielle I OFI Omar
Kotani Salwa Fosse sorry Ronnie Bravo
Jimmy
so Maha Nicholas Chacon II Alexis boot a
re no sigh ache Sylvia harbor le
Nazarene Aisha Garbi Nilo far sahabas
Imani Michael Charles brats Minh City
son Malik wet sawara - young team or DNA
Syed L mama Niccolo giarelli Abu go war
Francesca Brando ray no Mason TiVo
pausing Auggie
Francois Xavier Pagano
Sebastian Darko Jonathan
Gina Gagnon Sara Bell Heba Yan gang
janata Guarini jean-baptiste juillet on
ray they know blintz Victor Meatwad
Matthew repair sterile mandolin Nicola
may carbon Florian man Yi Vivian Anglian
Leslie Cheung Victor Benjamin Brokaw
Stanislaus miss Lynd Adrian Celestin
Quay to Pauline album Britney
Mukhopadhyay Lindsay Kang ste groom
going and dr. Vetra morio Leopold Bailey
Carmen Christian days young
Stephanie a ski
Audrey Selassie tebow bond - daran tank
our pond of sing you a whoo
Oliver met - asked Roberto Francisco
Valdes shocky Ganesh Kumar nail upon
Alfredo
sanabria Kira marine Chevelle Oh Joseph
Lloyd
Yaman Ryan Scott Hoffman
Jeremy t2 saying who Jung Choi they gone
Choi sang chul bay dong hoon Oh Jung
Hyun Seong suck young o zu b asana Nagi
Joseph sherek
Thomas Nikola cos Ian honest Mitsos
Athanasius board solace Andy Missoni
SonicWALL taro Mitchell Joseph Morris
rob van Haren sterling read weights
washin yow
hongyi whoo
Partha car Shawn SIA John go Michael
Sebastian masu low chen foo Steven
Andrew Morse Edwin Chuck
Lucian Wang Demetrios hanji Gabriel been
high on Keith Martin
Molina Monica yang orally Morla Jeremy
Samuel Edmonds
Jong Hyun Lee po-han Quan Chi Yin Lin
kunihiko sender Avanti dark are Vera
Cooper
pazi's new carnie Eric Andrew mr. Fred
go Ying light soi-yah ye Lin Nemeth Chan
ishik Ethan John Monday loop major
Jonathan Thomas Belmonts Stefan anglers
Audrina he Menace Passos cherrim bitty
pan Jawa con su one Elliott Elio green
blocks young Aaron you Pashu yay she ray
whoo jonathan de hoon chain Ling Yin yay
wait son whoo David Fang or Shula a him
pee poo Yong JA honey
Lawrence ignites go Brenda ink gray
squawk
Arisa Maury Sri lecture me
subramanian Cynthia Maria hide are
adjacent Claire guard Howie
dang we Cho Lynn yang Ying you meow
David Powell Abrams Cheng you Lynn Jung
Jung Hwan
turn your phone Karen beer sing Ghorab
Prabhu gonca Anupam Barba Daniel bono me
a poor Agarwal dear just Sonny young ye
Tan Cheng bang tan leerin Desmond who
John who John Zhang Jie Fung Lee Fong
who Joe Zhu Bing Wu heaping shoe Quan
Shin Ji Hoon hyung Lee hanyan go Dominic
poon Wilson we you a sim Edwin Lee Joon
Hui low Sameer Azhar miles Freedman Yan
VIN Zhang Shelton liao darn shame chin
Jenai are
ayo bean Yong ping blue hear you Wong
wanan Gong house Eric lino and deaf Oh
Ludovic Joseph Abdi Farah Michael
Frimpong mohammed el Trahan Sergio Rico
Jaime Koretz Minh Bharadwaj velour why
box Sahar on chin Jai jawan Andy Jia
Sheng song me Yong Chi way drunk go g zu
Chao you hiding Shirley Li Chen Lu
thomas-john
Aditya shriven us monstery a beam and on
Majumdar super in June Soccer Kappa via
Sharma Lentini wash wash Aditi with
Sharia Giambattista Sin Cara
Xavier Ortiz Eliana an eternal Silva
Christine Li Liang evangelist bellows
SATA hilarious Zachary's Jennifer marine
waltz Molly Laura flex Minh Lou care
multi oh pretty
Narayan Swati Kumar
nirav Vasa vucciria our Bashara nirav
Shah dreaming Shah Nikhil Arora Sidharth
Sharma
so not das Chintan Shah Howard Alexander
sights
Pynchon who being ray Yong Li hua Lin
Lee a foo NASA pan pan Tanya she to Ma
Peche upon P Japan Ratana sook Leland
Nimish pretty Malik Aditya Nayak
sumon sugar a party
some vanilla abhishek Agarwal
he Manchu Amati APA Tiwari sanshin
Agrawal derp in go al-biruni
goon a son I'm Olga Varsha Rama pop/rock
- Raju
Shrinivas needed a volu Abdul Hamid
Mohammed Gondor
Fahad Majeed Hassoun Anju Agrawal Akash
van Tina :
no Rana Daniela Suarez Adrienne fry
unkicked Malhotra Roy Hyun Jin Han
challenger Gert Abdullah Mamun Kimberly
morges Manas John Michael sink awaits
Stanley Ekman Snelson
ladies and gentlemen congratulations to
the class of 2009 we will close these
class day exercises with the singing of
stand Columbia and roar lion roar by the
cliffhangers we welcome you to sing
along the lyrics can be found in your
program we ask that you remain seated
until the recession has completed there
is another graduation ceremony right
after this so we ask that everyone and
all our guests exit to the right and
please join us on the Hamilton lawn for
a reception again congratulations
graduates
nowadays we can brain spirochetes again
here the lighting board is right welcome
at Morningside follow the blue and
once again ladies and gentlemen help me
congratulate our newest alumni the class
of 2009